hello I'm John Leavitt pleased to be
here with Chris Williamson and we're
today we're following up on our campaign
with Tyne Tees models where we're
talking about different aspects of life
mental health and other issues on how
people sort of realize who they are and
where they're clean and crisp can I just
ask you to introduce yourself and tell
us a little bit about you
so hi I'm Chris Williamson I'm a model
with Tyne Tees I have been for 11 years
now I'm a club promoter from Newcastle
I've done a little bit of reality TV
stuff company director for an events
company and I also do a podcast called
modern whistle
excellent well thank you for being with
us today and for come share your story
so Chris if we just roll back a little
bit from you've got a big career there
when you're doing an awful lot of things
and we have not chat beforehand one of
the things that most people might know
you from is from love Ireland yep right
so could you just because you made some
interesting points about how that
affected you and you know what that show
did for you yeah that make sense
interesting yeah so I think when a lot
of people ask what did you get out of
the show or how was it being on there
what they're expecting to hear is I got
a lot of social proofing I got to have
easi girls for the next couple years I
got to have free bottles and stuff in
nightclubs whereas for me what happened
was I was delivered a fatal dose of
contrast between a group of people who
were the person that I was acting out so
I was pretending to be this lad around
town promoted for 10 years and I lived
for four weeks undiluted with people who
do live and breathe that and what
happened was it very quickly highlighted
to me hang on that's not the person that
you actually are you thought it was and
having seen them 24/7 you were like yeah
okay
that's that's definitely not what I am
that means that there's a problem
problem requires solution and the
solution was I need to go on a bit of a
journey of emotional intelligence
learning and some self-discovery
introspective work and come out the
other side to try and actually work out
who I was who I think especially in the
nightlife industry there's a very
typical mold that people expect you to
be in and the deeper that you grease
that groove the more successful that you
can be right
people want archetypal roles they want
the hero the maid and the villain they
want to be able to put people into very
particular kind of boxes and one of the
things for me I think having a slightly
more eclectic mix of interests leads
people to not get you quite so easily
and what that means is they don't
resonate with you straight away and
given a choice between honesty and
acceptability yeah a lot of the time you
choose the latter reason being that you
don't want to say something that's
alarming or contrary or subtle near
because people don't get it so how is
your mood when you're on there because
you talked about having to win lots of
different masks all the time and when
you're wearing masks you at some stage
you lose sense of yourself as well if
you knew it in the first place
and so if I suppose the starting point
is before you move went on to the show
did you consciously feel you were having
to play a role or was it subconscious at
that stage to fit in if that makes sense
so I think with regards to the show I
had a pre-made idea of what they wanted
from me and what I should do to be
successful with regards to the show and
the show the show actually itself wasn't
that big of a deal it just ended up
being the kind of the peak of this
particular experience it was the top of
this particular story arc for me going
and just a little the right amount of
catalyst that was going to springboard
me towards a life that was a little bit
more virtuous after having done the
introspective work but beforehand so
I've suffered with depression for a long
time I think naturally I'm quite a
depressive person i if you roll a a
choice down the top of a fence I'm
always gonna fall off on the side of
catastrophe right not on this side of
success yeah that's my presumption all
the time I think that I work in an
industry which is very changeable look
nights as anyone who's ever been out and
been in the club scene for a while knows
it's very very quickly paid
and it means that you don't end up with
a lot of security because work was my
life for a long time I think that fed
back into what would have probably
already been some existing levels of
anxiety and so on and so forth as we
only so the way the depression and
anxiety manifested itself for me was
that I would tend to stay in bed for a
long time so I would refuse to get out
of bed or I couldn't bring myself to get
out and it's it's while you will work in
the nighttime economy or yes yes so if
you weren't working were you locking
yourself away all the time this would
come in period right so I don't patches
I'd have patches of it and one of the
worst things is whether things it's
really insidious about running your own
company is that when you're the boss
there's no one to tell you not to do it
yeah like I'm not accountable to anybody
and I can I can make up my own excuse
our meal today I'm tired today I mean
whatever whatever I'll just not say
anything and like who's gonna who's
gonna shout out yeah like there's no one
above me so it's all it's all on me and
yeah that meant that meant that
liberation was actually oddly worked
against me that but yeah so depression
for me manifested itself in terms of me
I would stay in bed I would get myself
into negative thought loops yeah I think
a lot of the time when people don't have
something very very tacit that is the
cause of their depression when it's this
kind of nebulous sense of dread this
drowning in thoughts that really don't
have a reason or a purpose to them I
haven't been through some psychological
catastrophe not a major one I haven't
been I haven't had any incredibly
traumatic events anything like that
and yet I was still suffering with
depression and that thought loop of the
shame behind being defeated by
essentially what I felt is nothing I
haven't the nothing catastrophic
happened and I still am getting defeated
by this and I can't count off then there
was a lot of shame associated with that
and I thought like I shouldn't be like
this I should be able to do with it etc
etc etc so how old we were when you
first became aware that there you might
be subject to low moods depression and
these sort conditions that you
but I think I always have so I remember
it unis so right like late teens 1920
right and you know badly enough it took
me until I was on live Islander 27 and I
still didn't really have the tools in my
arsenal to be able to deal with it rude
so you know I I suffered with these
batches of depression
depressive periods for a long time and
yeah so the the love allen thing came
about and like i say what it wasn't
about it wasn't about being on the show
it wasn't about the actual experience it
was just about the fact that it became a
little mountain it was like the zenith
of everything that had come together
before that right and it sounds like
infer from what was saying it was a
catalyst as much for though for that
point to change that so before moving on
to more discussing that and what what
those changes were and what helped you
in the period beforehand what support
help who did you work people around you
aware of how you felt not really a talk
or did you get a nice ask for her help
gnostic no i didn't so I mean that was a
I say one of the problems was that I I
was associating being vulnerable ie
opening up with being weak which is
wrong as far as I'm concerned showing
your vulnerabilities is one of the
strongest things that you can do and
yeah it meant that I was I was solely at
the mercy of whatever experience I was
going through I'm an only child
so I don't have close family like that
we don't have a broad family outside of
that either and the club promo world is
inherently a very transactional set of
relationships and if you're not being
tremendously virtuous or connecting with
if you're not connecting with people
that are on a similar level to yourself
and have similar interests etc etc it
can be really lonely at times which
sounds Converse right when we're running
a club night and I've got 2,000 people
who all know my name that have just gone
through the doors and yet you can be
stood on the front door and actually
feel quite alone yeah so yeah it was
it's an interesting dynamic especial
when people see you know for the people
who do know what I do or who I am you
see the 8,000 followers on Instagram you
see the you know going away on holidays
running club nights for a lot of people
that sounds like a dream life and it was
a lot less about the quantifiable
metrics of success and a lot more about
me not understanding my own mind so did
you enjoy it though so I get a sense a
real sense of fulfillment from
succeeding from overcoming tasks and so
on and so forth
my passion for partying itself has waned
a little but I still enjoy we've just
gone through freshers week standing on
the front door of a club that you've
worked like you've worked up to for two
months and seeing keys out the door and
you know that there's still a buzz
behind that regardless of the fact that
I'm drinking a water instead of a beer
like you know there's still a lot of
excitement behind that and the jobs
always being fulfilling me my business
partner have started it and we've been
going for 10 years it does fulfill me
but I don't think that the atmosphere of
the industry overall is fantastic for
mental health I think that it's a hyper
hyper masculine especially for the guys
there's a mold that most good promoters
are expected to fit yeah and showing
vulnerability show showing any real
intellectual virtue is it's just not
part and parcel of it it's
vlad's and birds and booze and you know
I mean like yeah it's that it's not
introspective work and have your red
collar of Ellie's new book and did you
see Jordan Pete's and so the most recent
yeah yeah yeah so if those are your if
those your interests we come back to
given a choice between honesty and
acceptability yes use a lot so if you
could and I think this is a really
important point because clearly although
you were in an industry that you're
actually sort of enjoying you know you
get validation from you're getting
connections with people it's still quite
transitory so actually you've got all
those relationships around you I suppose
where did you before you made the
changes
we're gonna go on talk to about where
did you get that sorted did you have
those deeper relationships with any
other source not really
which I guess is quite sad to think of
the fact that you had to add girlfriends
and and you know they've gotten super
super well but it was like before I did
the introspective work that allowed me
to begin to uncover some of my biases
and some of my beliefs and start to live
with a lot more integrity and virtue and
speak my truth forward and enact the
logos as Jordan Peterson would say
before I did that it was like a place
the glass ceiling on top or a glass
floor on the depth of connection I could
have with someone right and that was
because I wasn't prepared and firstly I
don't think I actually knew who I was to
a broad degree I'd played the
acceptability over honesty game so many
times that I didn't even know what
honestly for myself meant yeah
and yeah it was you know I'm used to
being on my own I grew up on my own any
only child who is listening will know
the exact same feeling that it is your
under socialized it is impossible via
parents to socialize view as an only
child to the same level yes someone
that's got siblings it does not matter
how social be how sociable your parents
are it is impossible and I think that
carried forward as I got later in life
that I thought well I've dealt with
loneliness and anxiety and stuff like
that before because that was to one
degree or another was a part of my
upbringing so that this is just the next
step maybe this is maybe this is just
what life is then yeah so
that was that was that I guess like the
depth of connection the depth of
relationship was quite low that's not to
say that I didn't have good friendships
which are dead but again I'd place these
barriers at place confines around how
deep I was prepared to go and how deep I
was able to go as well so when you go
back if you think back to that period
because it's it's quite an interest run
we hear this sort of this these
discussions around people having to play
certain roles plait puts her masks on
not just so I'm not talking about the TV
show but actually through life when you
come through and actually when we're
talking about recovery the hospice and
Kivi kicking drugs or dealing with
anxiety or dealing with alcohol for
example it's actually about looking at
yourself for the first time and quite
often that's one of those sort
challenges if you were to look at the
circle of people you you sort of knew
previously before you had those deep
relationships you can say how many
people around you
can you look back on and see also aware
in those sort of asks well it's
difficult isn't it because everyone's
good at playing again yeah it's
difficult to work out who is wearing the
mask because a lot of people were
incredibly effectively yeah like I say
you know there's a anyone who would have
known me three years ago five years ago
maybe if they had a really really good
sense of awareness they would have gone
yeah chris is not quite not quite a
hundred percent or whatever but I think
I I think I played a pretty successful
game at hiding my depressive pewds and
that's not to sales depressed all the
time at its worst how did how did your
depression sort of feel at that time are
there any particular instances that sort
of jump out to you no unfortunately so I
didn't have a single traumatic event it
was just this pervasive consistent
underlying low-level anxiety big lack of
gratitude big lack of compassion self
love it wasn't that say nothing
catastrophic happened
but there was periods where it would be
three or four days where I wouldn't get
out of bed broadly I'd maybe go up the
shop and I'd see people and I'd make
excuses it was a couple of periods where
it was so three or four days without
leaving the house because I just
couldn't bring myself to to leave I
didn't want to see people I didn't want
to have to do things and we were doing
well the business was successful we were
able to take over and I was able to in
the same way that a drug or an alcohol
addict can hide their substance abuse
from people I was able to hide my
depression from people because I'd
played this role of being big dick at
around town you know really cool his
sort of aspirational guy remembering
that we've got a team of we have 400
staff to work for us and between myself
my business partner we're supposed to be
the two leaders of that company we're
supposed to be setting an example for
people like what sort of an example is
if your boss can't get yourself out of
bed for years so there was a lot of
shame associated with that and I think I
felt a lot I didn't really even know at
the time was just so ignorant I didn't
even know that I was at the mercy of
something I just thought that's what
life was like ruined and I think a lot
of that was just you to not putting in
the time I wasn't I wasn't learning
about depression like I had never once
typed into Google what is depression
yeah like there was I'm pretty certain
I've maybe had one or two anxiety
attacks in my life and I remember it
happening and we going in I wanted to go
and have a shower because I was shaking
and I thought I'm shaking I must be cold
but had a shower in the warm shower and
I didn't stop shaking as I got weird and
then it took it was like two years three
years later I was like oh that's
probably an anxiety attack when I read
about it I'm like how it's just it was
so bizarre that he was staring me in the
face that I was suffering with
depression but I'd hidden it so well at
the shame associated with not with the
outcomes which were not getting out bad
yeah big people they were so I was so
worried about being rumbled for those
that I was I hadn't even put the work in
to work out what I was suffering with
myself oh yeah so and I think it's a
really interesting point this because
actually what you've highlighted a very
classic behaviors which are indicative
of these sort of condition
but actually in you've said a few times
well you know you hand put the work in
to understand what it was would you have
been capable of doing that at that time
because a lot of this is comes down to
self awareness in other people and as
you said the shame of the behavior of
staying in bed in a way it's it's sort
of been quite hard on yourself
very much about but that's because of
the journey you come on how much do you
think stems you said there was no sort
of major trauma that stimulate these two
things what about self-esteem from where
you're so on how did you view yourself
when you right at the start of these
when you sort of put these masks on to
fit in or to develop in that industry do
you do you see where I'm coming for I
understand yeah I think I think I'm a
lot deeper than I gave myself credit for
and one of the problems of that was that
I my self-esteem now
yeah nowadays is very very heavily borne
of why why no how understanding and
compassionate and grateful I am for
things how I'm able to help other people
with stuff that's really fulfilling to
me like the podcast etc etc but because
I had none of those things in my life at
that time I was living this very
transactional relationship that was
people on the door of a club money in
money out etc etc and although it was
fun and that was the life that a lot of
other young people lead you know like
the planning lifestyle and I didn't fit
that mold and that wasn't what an
enjoyable life meant to me but because I
didn't know anything else that was them
that was the model I was following so
there was a non conscious disconnect
from actually your whole life no alien
what you were living in what we were
doing very much so
so if we move on to how actually you
mean we talked a little bit earlier
about how love Island became that's what
a catalyst that's although you talked
about apex that came into what was the
the first process is thought process
that you thought oh hang on there's more
to the more to me than this
how did that come about so I didn't I
didn't have particularly you Rica moment
with that and I think one of the things
one of the things that kind of comes up
from this story generally is that you
mentioned just before why or how long it
occurred for and why would you have been
able to yeah would you have been able to
get stuck in and do the work early on
and we all like to think that we can
expedite our progress right we all want
to think that we can get to this by
reading a book summary or by listening
to a podcast that cites quotes yeah
without context and without the right
mindset to accept these sort of things
and without really really working hard
in spending what you'd call in the gym
time and attention yeah without doing
that all of this is a waste and the
perfect example for this is anyone who's
listening at home think about the last
time you scroll down your Instagram feed
and you saw an inspirational quote that
someone put up why did that
inspirational quote not change your life
it's because there wasn't enough time
and attention you weren't in the right
frame of mind it didn't resonate with
you there was no context so for me
weirdly enough you probably write that
even if I'd had the tools at my disposal
when I was 24 25
I just wasn't for some bizarre reason I
don't really know what it is I wasn't
ready I wasn't ready to to make that
realization and there's a level of
maturity that I think that you need to
you need to get to I'm confident I would
have been able to probably hurry that
along a little bit had I have started
exposing myself to some more mindful
content before them but yet to sort of
jump on that point
you totally right to talk about was
there a moment or what can I remember
around about that time that kind of
started to propel me towards doing the
introspective work hmm there wasn't
anything in particular there was a
number of experiences on the show stuff
that wasn't aired where I just remember
being sat there and thinking this really
is not me
here in one of the lads talked about the
car the AMG Mercedes Black Edition 63
6.3 liter this car he was gonna get and
then for me to find out the next day
that you didn't have a driving license I
was like
this is not my world at all and that's
one of the sticks in my mind that made
me think right like you're not these
people and that is not for me to say
that the guys who are there in any way
more or less valuable in terms of what
they have to say it's just that we
weren't existing on the same no it's
different and I think the the real issue
for them that may not be a disconnect no
they were living so this is why I say
they were living their truths yes they
lived their truths on there and that's
what made them good cast members and
that's what made me a bad cast member
right the reason that I wasn't
tremendously successful um loved Island
was because I wasn't speaking my truth
forward the reason I wasn't speaking my
truth forward just because I was
terrified of what would happen if I did
yes so perfect example I'm sat down on
the first night anyone who's seen season
1 episode 1 I'm sat down with Danielle
she's next to me in the bed and she
looks at this tree and it's outside of
the lines had never made it on the on
the other looks at this tree and
mentioned something about it
can't know what it is and I just like
ripped off some quote I it's because of
the blob of the Coriolis effect of the
earth or whatever it might be and she
turns oh that's really clever like can
you say some more clever things and I
was like [__] [__] like that's not what
that's not what Chris in this situation
is supposed to say so I'm that right I
need to start playing the game again I
need to start filming myself down or I
need to begin this rhetoric which is
more typical to what I think people want
from me so that's a good example I guess
I think that this is really interesting
because what really jumps out from the
conversations we've had and just
previously is how destructive not being
yourself and listening to that to the
real you is even if it mean we're all
going through this life it all takes
different stages to actually discover or
actually realize we've got to discover
who you are first
yeah but actually the impact of not
doing it yeah it can be disastrous it's
very very bad so john pease and anyone
who's listening and you knows my
podcasts is my favorite thinker and he
talked about enacting the logos which is
speaking not true forward yeah and for
me learning to be able to tell the truth
was probably the most important thing
that I could do and that meant truth if
I felt vulnerable truth if I felt sad
truth if I was interested in something
truth if I had an opinion about what
some
some of my friends were doing and very
quickly the truth the truth to me is
kinda like a superpower right because it
insulates you from ever being wrong it
insulates you from ever being
uncompassionate because all that you're
doing is speaking forward what's inside
of you but it's quite difficult for
people to tell the truth it sounds
bizarre cos it's one thing that
everyone's always got their disposal all
the time supposedly you actually done a
lot at the time when you look inside you
don't really know what you think you
don't have the truth inside so how much
do you think is that a because for all
those things that we touch on around
things by fear of either upsetting
people or of changing rejection and then
we're straight back into the I mean
that's the Cora self-esteem well that's
really what we're talking about just
coming back to practical times because
it's it's some people who might be
listening or transitivity who are
struggling themselves with depression or
anxiety or some of the issues even just
just not knowing who they are but they
realize not who they are
what were the practical things steps
that you took what were the first things
that you did how did you get on this
path of self-discovery so I recently did
had to write the about me for the
podcasts that I do and as a part of that
I tried to distill down what I'd done
over the last few years because there
was a point that I was at which a lot of
people may be at there's a point that
I'm at now which is better now I'm in no
way self actualized I know not you know
I still suffer with depressive episodes
and I don't really know where I'm going
but I've got a good idea of the path
that I took to get you and I understand
the tools that I used I think the first
thing that the the first time that I
really really started to relook at
depression was when I read Johann Hari
book lost connections Marie and in that
he talks about how depression currently
is being diagnosed as an imbalance of
chemicals in the brain here and a lot of
people will believe that that's the
cause of depression or that that's their
reason for depression one of the
problems with that apart from the fact
that it's wrong based on what a lot of
the research says another problem is
that it makes you feel very helpless
about that like what you're supposed to
do if you've got this imbalance of
the same as being diabetic I mean let's
stop being diabetic allow yourself to
process glucose that way I can't in
exactly the same way as that's the
situation it puts you in here's why I
realized very quickly was that I wasn't
fulfilling any of the foundational
principles that I needed to to at least
make myself
prepare to be happy forget the self
esteem and the introspective work and
all of that sort of forget all of the
more kind of ephemeral nebulous stuff
and just focus on the fundamentals a
consistent sleeping and waking pattern I
was a club promoter so for a long time I
had a very chaotic one I still do but
I'm able to mitigate it now because I've
got a plan in place seven to eight hours
sleep a night if you have under six and
a half hours sleep for five days in a
row you begin to start showing these
same effects as someone that's
pre-diabetic me that's not good no sleep
and wake nutrition around about the
times when I was going to be doing a lot
of partying or a lot of work I'd get up
have a bowl of cereal at 1:00 in the
afternoon have a Domino's at 6:00 p.m.
and then go back on the lush but that's
not fantastic your brain and your money
is built purely from the things that you
put in your mouth like what's my body
made out of so made out of Budweiser and
Domino's like that's not that's not a
very good environment to exist in so I
got my sleeper I got my nutrition right
I've always exercised but it wasn't
consistent I changed to do CrossFit
which meant I was spending a lot more
time outside a lot more fresh air big
open spaces it's a lot more social in
terms of in terms of connections I had I
had friends at the time and I'd then
doubled down on the ones who I was able
to talk with most about the things that
were most meaningful to me I started up
a podcast with the guys who that really
resonated with and I got to spend a lot
more time with them so for me focusing
on the fundamentals get your sleep right
get your nutrition right make sure that
you're exercising consistently you have
a job that at least makes you feel
remotely fulfilled where you've got the
the level of creativity that you desire
within your life a little bit of
independence start to build some
relationships with people that think
like you and that you can be
honest truthful with an actually
genuinely care about you on Jordan
Pearson's rules for life is be friends
with people who want the best feet yeah
absolutely and then after I'd got those
things right the trickle-down effect of
that was that I was able to I was able
to have something like compassion for
myself self compassion was then able to
come in because I was able to think well
okay like I'm the clarity of my thought
is at least remotely okay because I'm
not built out of Budweiser and dominoes
on three hours so yeah so yeah after
that came learning yeah but obviously
their your your platforms from which you
then built which enabled you to start
looking up actually the wide you if that
makes sense exactly what I mean one of
the things from what we have recovery we
look at things you don't exercise asleep
says is really important to understand
your sexuality and actually to have a
positive appreciation for that slightly
differently maybe to where you might
have had before when you're gonna be
club promoter et cetera you know we
won't go into that but have you changed
your has that been a feature of how you
view things as well or has that changed
also in terms of your pattern or your
sex life or how that works is it less
transactional yes and because obviously
this is one of the big disconnects is
where you have a transactional
relationship with people they either
personal physical or whatever I mean
actually it changes how the impacts on
you as well
I understand I don't think I think for
me thankfully sex was one of those areas
that didn't ever suffer in terms of I
was never self reflective about it all
kind of self abusive about the way that
I was using sex or I was being used for
sex out
put it across that wasn't ever a real
concern for me but certainly now I view
any relationship with a lot more it's a
lot more sacred to me again to go back
to Jordan peace and be attractive to
many women but choose one yeah that's
the I think it is emotionally a more
healthy way to be as a man yeah and I I
think there's very few people very few
men
foom that's actually not true yeah and I
think that they'd be very surprised to
hear it because they believe that the
zenith of successes of man is be
attractive to many women and sleep with
even more yeah absolutely
whereas actually and this is really at
the core because it's about getting in
touch with your the emotional side of
you and to see how the impact it has not
just for that short period but actually
these sort of relationships are more
than that and actually quite often where
you see people and you see it with
things like sex addiction porn addiction
ones like this really in all of these
issues actually they become the issues
come to the disconnect from who you are
that actually causes the problem I think
if it's if you're on a night out and you
like no one knows what the right number
of dates is need to have before you
sleep with someone but it's probably not
one like as a rule of thumb it's
probably not one and the reason it's not
one it is because if it's one you're
low-hanging fruit mmm by definition you
are low-hanging fruit like is that what
you really want to think of yourself as
a sexual partner that you're low-hanging
[__] fruit so yeah I think with
regards to the sex thing I treat
relationships a lot more sacred now I'm
even for the girls that I'm around and I
don't have a sexual relationship with
I'm just generally a lot more
compassionate to them and it that that
to me is more fulfilling than a lot of
them well all of the one-night stands
yeah you know that to me that's it's
easy come easy go
another vehicle which sometimes people
well quite often people hurt themselves
with is alcohol now we were talking
earlier on that you've done number of
sitri where you go drive for set at
certain periods and just Okolona how's
that helped you you think so I've done
six months sobriety twice now and that
was the first one was about eighteen
months ago and that was what I really
really wanted to double down on on my
personal progression there's a blog
called the illuminated Man and if you
search that there's something called
monk mode which they talk about focusing
on the three eyes which are
introspection introspective work
isolation and current of what the third
one is anyway the point is that you
isolate yourself for a significant
period of time from the things that you
know that a bad view and to me alcohol
knocked me off so I'm naturally a
depressive person for anyone who's
listening if you have to press it
tendencies and your hangovers are worse
than the night out you're netting and
negative give up alcohol and it just
sounds so paradigm shifting the people
want to know because I go out on a night
out because that's what everyone else
does it's like oh yes that's fine but
you don't have to know like you do not
need to go on a night out and wake up
the next day and hate yourself because
that's what's gonna happen if you
continue to do the same thing with a bad
result like you know what's going to
happen the next time you go out you get
leathered it's not gonna change the way
you feel the next day is not gonna
change so for me I decided to do
sobriety it meant that I'd double down
on being productive and for two periods
of six months I did it then recently
came back had a couple of nights out in
Newcastle neither of them work on one of
them were traumatic or tremendously bad
but very quickly I just thought like
this isn't this isn't for me anymore
I didn't enjoy the night out anywhere
near enough to suffer the consequences
the next day and the thing that's really
insidious about alcohol is that you get
diminishing margins of return of
enjoyment over time but you get an
exponential increase in suffering and as
soon as those two lines cross each other
all that you're doing is making yourself
hurt for no more enjoyment absolutely
and and I mean again this is people have
to make their own choices quite often
what we see is what the relationship is
with the bit the vehicle that we're
talking about I've talked about hiring
lesser vehicles for example we assess
their alcohol beard relationships which
are unhealthy etc with alcohol you've
also got the with it being a chemical
you've got a naturally depressing
it's a depressant so it's going to
reinforce anything and it actually
really cuts across if people are on
things like antidepressants result so
it's an interesting so we're we're next
for you Chris what do you think what's
where's your path heading now not too
sure where my path I didn't know I I get
maybe a message add a message every
couple of days from people who listen to
the podcast that say they had to really
changed them and its Howard and that
I've never had someone come out of a
club night then come up to me and say
man you know what it is like I was
feeling alone or I was on the brink of
destruction or is this than the other
book when I heard those banging shoes
and those one-pound Jager bombs in there
it just changed me and you're like
that's never happened that never
happened to me right and I didn't know
how hungry I was for helping people
until they occurred and again it all
comes back to this transactional
relationship it's very very short-lived
etc etc yeah moving forward I want to
continue to help people understand how I
got from where I was to where I am now
right in a sentence that's it I I did a
lot of introspective work in analogy
that I use his introspective work is a
lot like turning over dirty storms for
everyone that you turn over that's clean
there's 20 they're disgusting and have
something terrifying underneath and you
need to be incredibly brave to be able
to do that like it it isn't easy to it's
not easy to ask yourself questions that
you really don't even know want to know
the answer of so for me spending a lot
of time with mindful content further
learning about myself further learning
about evolutionary psychology learning
about cognitive biases and and spending
time around
people who hold me to a high standard so
some of the rules for life that I try
and stick to I've got 40 that are on my
wall
number one is tell the truth number two
is do not do the things that you hate
mmm number three is act so that you can
tell the truth by how you act those
first three rules if you can get those
first three done you're on a really good
path to actually living a life that is
pretty fulfilling you know I think to
summarize that for anyone who's
listening find me on Instagram give me a
message I'd love to help you but focus
on telling the truth yeah focus on
living your life as close to virtue as
you can find work out what your
principles are so principles are things
that you will not compromise on no
matter what the situation is and derive
from that your virtues in life right
every time that you compromise on your
principles your brains keeping a karma
like a doorman stood on the door of one
of my club nights he's keeping the
counter one two three four and that
that's really that for me was the first
part of losing self-respect was the fact
that I wasn't even prepared to be myself
and then I've done it for so long I
didn't know who I was so tell the truth
find some people that you know that a
good for you
rule number six be friends with people
who want the best for you people who
want the best for you don't tell you
what you want to hear they tell you what
they need to hear so it's not giving you
comforting words it's not feeding you
sugary sweets it's telling you what you
need to hear so if you're around friends
that keep on just being yes meant to you
I'll never question you when you do
something wrong they're not really
friends they're just people there yes
ma'am get you sleeping weight cycle side
slightly nutrition out get some
relationships they're meaningful clean
your room tidy up your room a domain of
competence that you're going to be able
to live with it and then listen to
Johann Hari on Joe Rogan podcast is
wooden believable about depression
listen to Matthew Walker on Joe Rogan
it's about sleep listen to any of the
things with Jordan Pete's and on there
listen to any other things with some
Harris on that if you manage to spend 50
hours of time and attention listening to
those podcasts you will begin to
understand what the path is that you
need to take to yourself now that's
great Chris and just to add something
else you mentioned earlier in terms of
the medical model that sort of chemical
model that some
depressions imbalance etc unfortunately
that's the mindset that has shaped
treatment services and actually if you
look at the level of antidepressants
which have gone up right in some areas
by 300% in the past 10 years this is the
this is the what actually you're seeing
and it is the impact of that mindset so
if you've left had one message to sort
of say in terms of to anybody who's
listened this if you who who actually
don't know what those questions are
would it be them would be to talk to
family friends would it be to listen
these podcast or a combination of though
what what would you suggest to somebody
as a final message I'd say that you need
to as a final message I think that you
need to first off find some people who
you genuinely can connect to it right
it's difficult for people if you're a
rugby lad who happens to have a little
bit of a deep side to them and you're
around or the rugby lads it's gonna be
tough but we're all connected by the
internet like go on read it work out
what it is that you enjoy and go on read
it and there will be a community of
people in there who will think like you
know for me I made the majority of my
transformation introspectively or
emotion in terms of emotional
intelligence through crushing amounts of
appropriate content you know so I
listened I watched I read a ridiculous
amount and I could have done I'm sure
there would have been a much more
logical way to have followed it through
and I'm sure anyone who's listening will
be able to find a much more expedited
way of doing it but share time and
attention and just listening to things
that you care about listening to things
that help you understand yourself
because there's more connections in a
single square centimeter of human brain
tissue than there are stars in our
galaxy our inner universe is so complex
and people just presume it doesn't come
with an instruction manual like it
doesn't at all and I don't know the
cheat codes to it either like it's not
like someone's got unlimited happiness
g-code sat in the back pocket it's that
they have got some habits some
principles that they stick to on a daily
basis that they know that are good for
them and so I think plan some goals is a
good way to do it with Celia logical
beings and Tilos it means target the
teleological beings so make yourself
some plans what you want to be doing to
be happy okay so you want to feel
fulfilled in six months time or in 12
months time how are you going to
instantiate that on a daily basis I'm
gonna get up at the same time I'm gonna
eat well I'm gonna be grateful another
thing that I would suggest using to
anyone is generally like gratitude
journaling but yeah I think as a parting
note everything that you've got about
your on of the vast majority that you
have as a parting note anything that
you're suffering with is within your
control to change you may need some help
from some friends you may need some help
from a doctor but changing your
environment and changing the basics will
make so much of a difference so much
more than relying on medication I the
the male fear of admitting to medical
problems is so pervasive that I never
ever once considered even thinking about
taking antidepressant because that would
have been even more shame and I mean
that's that's even worse like to think
that I wouldn't take a medication or
even ask for it because we were to try
and help me i but it shows how insidious
depression can be absolutely but yeah
you know anyone who needs to speak i'm
on instagram i'm on facebook email me or
message me i'll always reply that's
great Chris thanks very much in real
pleasure
you
[Music]